and we're really pleased to be here and
pleased to be giving a talk together
because as we're saying neither of us is
given an in-person talk in two and a
half three years so 20 minutes each
seems like a reasonable amount of time
to speak loudly so we'll see how it goes
and we'll see how our voices hold
um so I'm Katie Shelton and I'm Megan
Finn hi I'll
um and today we're going to talk about a
case study that we've been working on
within a broader project focused on what
we're calling ethics governance in the
making which is a mouthful and we will
explain what we mean by that
um and we've had an opportunity to
present this work before
um two uh scholars in history of
technology and science and technology
studies which are the disciplines that
we sort of come out of but we haven't
had a chance to do it for this
interdisciplinarian audience so we're
really excited uh to have the chance to
do that today
um but with that said please ask if
there are things you want clarified
during the talk we're sort of working on
making it a talk that works in more
environments so uh please feel free to
ask
a little background about us and how we
arrived at this project
um we both teach policy and ethics
courses to students in information
studies Library science HCI and
um in the course of teaching those
classes we both discovered this thing
called the Menlo report and the Menlo
report
um ended up being for us something we
thought was a really interesting example
of Ethics self-governance a field coming
together to say these are going to be
ethics rules for our field I mean then
we asked our like computer security
colleagues about this and they didn't
know what it was and we thought that's
really interesting what's happening here
and as social scientists we wanted to
investigate this more
and the reason that we were really
interested in investigating this more is
because
um you know we have this perception that
uh
you know ethnic self-governance is is a
Hot Topic in computer science right now
um that self-governance the field of
computing is going through a real moment
of wanting to self-gov govern ethics
um and um and you know Menlo was 10
years ago but since then the tenor of
the ethics conversation around computer
science has really changed and has
ramped up in many ways um a range of
public examples plus some really
important academic work have highlighted
challenges in data and research Ethics
in uh the development of pervasive tools
of surveillance and in discrimination in
decision making systems and machine
learning systems so the ethics
governance in the making process of the
Menlo report was of real interest to
Megan and I
um as this within this moment now when
Computing is is confronting crises of
Ethics
um and we wanted to know what concurrent
efforts for self-governance learn from
this process 10 years ago
okay so this concept that we're
interested in ethics governance
um is and the idea that these are there
are networks of people in this case sort
of whole academic fields that are
attempting to resolve uncertainty about
um what is the right or wrong thing to
do through new rules new procedures or
new consequences and sometimes all three
um and those kinds of efforts are
happening like right on this campus as
well as in research communities that
both Megan and I are part of so for
instance Stanford's ethics and Society
review board engages researchers
um in uh early phases of AI research
through a procedures that consider the
societal risk of that research and they
attach funding consequences to those
decisions that's the consequences part
Megan was the author recently of the
national National academies report that
offered best practices for funding
agencies for academic organizations and
for individual researchers concerned
with responsible computing I was the
former chair of the Sig Kai research
Ethics Committee which is a volunteer
group that offers advice when papers in
Sid Kai conferences are flagged by
reviewers for having ethics issues so
these are all current examples of uh
ethics self-governance projects but
there are numerous historical examples
as well uh perhaps among the most famous
is the asilamar conference on
recombinant DNA which is a 1975 meeting
of to set voluntary guidelines for the
use of recombinant DNA in research
and then many of you if you've done
human subjects training at your
University may be familiar with the
Belmont report which was in 1976 effort
to identify ethical principles for human
subjects research and then of course
there's Menlo which would become the
subject of our case study Menlo took
place um almost a decade as I said
before the wave of recent controversies
and uh starting in 2009 a group of
computer scientists primarily as well as
lawyers in government security uh and
network measurement research folks
culminated got together and put together
guidelines for computer security and
network measurement research and that
culminated in this 2012 report
and so the recent history the fact that
all those folks are still active
researchers they're still around like we
could talk to them gave us the
opportunity to explore how is this work
done uh what are the ingredients in
self-governance efforts and then how do
those ingredients matter to the outcomes
and the impacts of the project
so Megan and I as I mentioned before
both have roots in science and
technology studies and we began framing
our interests in ethics governance and
ethics self-governance in that
literature
so we draw on the idea of constitutional
moments which are times when a field or
a group of people are renegotiating the
terms of unethical and ethical practice
so that's what's happening is there's a
constitutional moment and then we were
really interested in an idea called
ethics work or the idea of Ethics work
which is Malta zewitz's term for when
people have to do work in their like
labs and workplaces to cope with ethical
ambiguity so when you don't know what to
do you maybe talk about it with people
in your workplace you're doing work
right that's ethics work
and we're interested in kind of on the
other end of a spectrum from ethics work
ethics governance drawing on Rebecca
slayton's definition of governance as
networks trying to steer people in a
particular direction by either accepting
members into the network or cutting
members that don't go in the direction
they are wanting to go
so the contrast between ethics work on
the one hand sort of local ambiguity
resolving and ethics governance cutting
people from networks if necessary on the
other led us to a set of research
questions that are focused on how
localized ethics work becomes ethics
government governance on a bigger scale
when we call this bridge ethics
governance in the making it's a mouthful
term but it was the best we could come
up with we have better terms yeah so our
research questions became what sparks a
group of people to do the really
resource intensive work and you'll see
and it was really resource intensive of
imagining new governance for a field
um what challenges does governance in
the making present what's hard about it
and how does the work of envisioning new
governance influence what becomes seen
as ethical action and guidance for the
field
so the memo report gave us the chance to
answer these questions for a single case
study
localized ethics work has been occurring
in the computer security and network
measurement fields for decades the
computer security research Community has
long debated ethical questions like the
acceptability of monitoring Network
traffic
the political consequences of e-voting
and principles for handling
vulnerability disclosures there's lots
of localized ethics work happening in
computer security and so our project
began with the question of how and why
that those localized debates became this
governance effort
and so producing the mental report was
really an effort to move from Reliance
upon tacit Norms within labs to an
agreed-upon standard
and we analyzed the mental report
documents which included uh both uh the
Menlo report itself as well as a
companion piece that had case studies in
it we also analyzed several articles
about the report that were written by
report authors at the time
um and then we talked to authors so in
the final list of authors six of the
authors were active computer science
researchers in either Academia or
technical research institutes four were
working as lawyers or law Scholars two
were employed by the Department of
Homeland Security who funded the effort
and we're going to talk more about that
in a minute and two were working for in
research protection within a research
organization that means they were sort
of IRB ish if you know about irbs
um so we conducted interviews with 11 of
these 15 authors everybody who would
talk to us
um and discuss the work of with them of
creating the report how participants
became involved how the writing and
collaboration process was organized and
funded uh and the Legacy and influence
of the report
and we also analyzed separately ethics
statements in papers published within
network security and network measurement
conferences in the years after the
report
so the report itself
interestingly Builds on core principles
that were articulated in the 1979
Belmont report and that's the report
that shaped human subjects research
standards and the social sciences
um in the US and so Menlo adopted the
Three core principles of Belmont respect
beneficence and Justice they laid those
out as equally important to Computing
research
um so and in that move made a move where
they said Menlo said that decl that they
basically declared that Computing data
was human subjects data and would be
subject to these principles
um and in addition Menlo added a fourth
principle uh respect for Law and public
interest and we're going to trace how
that fourth principle came out of major
debates that were happening in the field
at the time
so through our analysis what we found
was that even in this case study of
technologists who were pretty
self-consciously crafting new ethics
principles that's what they came
together to do
um they was it was really a process of
what we call an STS pre-collage which
means bringing together what's available
at hand bringing together available
tools at hand this was not this was way
more prominent than sort of bringing
together of existing tools than say
moral reasoning from first principles um
we kind of thought
of wait
as as logical reflection and then coming
up with principles that you know come
from from for first um first standards
the first principles but it turns out
that crafting ethical principles is work
two like any other work like work in a
lab like work in a workplace
um and that bringing together and
adapting existing materials the stuff
that you know about turns out to be
really important so as research
communities in AI ethics and other
controversies in our spaces now begin
their work of governance in the making
I think it's going to be it's going to
be really necessary to decide who
participates to decide
um what uh what things we have at hand
right what principles are we going to
bring to these projects and a framework
for how to study how that happens ethics
in the making governance in the making
can help us understand uh these efforts
better and maybe be more reflective
about how we set them up in the first
place
so we suggest based on Menlo a framework
that incorporates five elements of work
um and we're going to walk through some
of them today the first is marshaling
the resources that are available all of
this is time and money so thinking about
the resources available really matters
to the outcomes
um background uh or the second is the
attempts to repair what is a group
trying to repair what wrongs have gone
on that have brought a group together to
try and fix those wrongs
third is attempts to anticipate the
future so we'll talk about how Menlo
participants were trying to deal with a
future that they couldn't see coming
um and particularly changes in
Technologies because that changes
quickly yeah
uh next was work to close or settle
existing controversies in the field so
to try and make some decisions about yes
this is okay no this is not okay
um and finally to resolve ethical
uncertainties as participants tried to
understand what practices are acceptable
so because ethics in the making is this
free collage process
um we see this list of five things as
not total you know it's not a necessary
but not sufficient right it's not
totally generalizable things will be
different in different places but we do
think it's helpful to understand the
process
um involved in what gets put into ethics
governance So today we're going to focus
on one two and four but we can also talk
about three and five if you are
interested
um in uh
um you know more details in the Q a
okay
so first we looked at the resources that
were marshaled for the Menlo project and
first among these resources were the
people involved it was the primary
resource involved with people whose
background and expertise impacted the
resulting guidance
for Menlo the actors involved and the
resources involved influence the content
of the report and they also as I'll talk
about influenced how successfully the
report was able to govern
Menlo was bootstrapped it was
bootstrapped through a U.S Department of
Homeland Security
existing program called predict predict
standard for or stood for protected
repository for the defense of
infrastructure against cyber threats
kind of a background
but predict is what they were trying to
do right predicting threats essentially
um and one of the many things predict
was a big program a big funding program
for academics but one of the big things
I sought to do was to enable data
sharing between academics about online
networks so that you would have a place
you could go to get say ISP data if you
needed ISP data so they wanted to do
data sharing
um and as part of their interest in data
sharing they started to run up against
ethical issues like privacy and things
like that where if you're sharing data
you might you might need to worry about
so predict the existence of predict
enabled Menlo almost entirely um and
then that enabling happened in a variety
of ways writing workshops we're
connected to predict Pi meetings so that
meant they generally occurred a day
before or a day after a pi meeting Pi
meetings are times when researchers are
required by their funders to show up and
be there and Report out and so what the
spent is there were a bunch of people
funded on predict who also became
involved with memo because it was pretty
accessible for them to be involved with
memo
um and uh it made it yeah it made it
easier for all these network security
folks to attend
um and so the co-location strongly
shaped participation within the project
uh the people who participated in the
report were primarily academic computer
scientists and were largely from the
network measurement and network security
subfields of computer science so it was
not really computer science but large it
was a pretty specific subset
um and then these researchers were
joined by a handful of people who were
recruited by predict organizers uh
primarily lawyers with expertise in
cyber security law
and so we think it's also important to
consider who wasn't uh at Menlo meetings
so traditionally
um ethicists and social scientists have
been part of big self-governance efforts
in various places
um for instance acilimar Belmont
um and they were absent from Menlo
proceedings um and an author you know
described us we reached out to a number
of people in the ethics Community who go
way back well-known names I won't say
the names we tried to evolve some of
them there weren't a whole lot of takers
partially because it was a volunteer
effort I think but also partially
because it was leaving the area they
have expertise in that's my gut feeling
so without Ephesus on the team the team
lacked at first he's to question the
coherency or appropriateness of those
Bell not mod principles to proceed from
perhaps concrete and concrete ethical
Frameworks that break a large work we
think is a result of who was in the room
right they were not philosophers to
start from first principles
um and you know it was hard to invent
new forms of ethical reflection that
might have been a better fit for
computer security without folks trained
to do that
um and the authors acknowledge this
limitation right like they were really
Frank about this in the introduction to
the report they wrote the report
deliberately does not explore alternate
ethical paradigms to Belmont and while
not discounting that there may be novel
implementations of the Belmont report
principles and applications that should
be considered it makes no definitive
recommendations in that regard right
this was a fight should we do something
Beyond Belmont they said Okay We're Not
Gonna We're not gonna go there
um and there's another further
limitation a few further limitations to
this group that I think are worth
talking about
um without social scientists the team
couldn't incorporate expertise on
sociality on inequality work practices
institutional Dynamics none of that
really showed up in the discussions
around the report
um that might have supported the
implementation of governance networks
right you can make recommendations
social scientists might have been
helpful in figuring out how to govern um
or how to get the governance Frameworks
working um so that's not there and
finally the authorship group uh
reflected the lack of racial and ethnic
diversity within computer science at the
time
um and and now limiting the standpoints
that were incorporated into the final
recommendations
so after the Menlo report was written
they still needed resources to circulate
the report to engage the envisioned
governance networks such as program
committees or institutional review
boards the groups that they thought
would help implement this and menlo's
transition from in the making to
actualized governance was really
challenged by both Logistics and
resources as a first step the team took
a path that had been modeled by Belmont
but was pretty unusual for computer
science codes of Ethics they published
the Menlo report in the Federal Register
which is the official channel for
sharing and requesting public feedback
on U.S government agency rules
um so the public change for the public
chance for comment had some advantages
um it differentiated Memo from many
Science and Technology self-governance
projects which have been critiqued for a
lack of public participation
um this was a channel for public
participation
um they didn't you know public
Representatives weren't part of writing
but they did have a chance to comment
but even government employees among the
report authors acknowledged the
limitations of the Federal Register as a
dissemination approach as an author told
us even still it's only people who
follow Washington that actually know
what the Federal Register really is
um the Menlo report was first published
online in December 2011 and it received
16 public comments so not a not a ton
um
so though the process of publishing
Menlo in the Federal Register was the
start of a process for federal agency
rulemaking ultimately the Department of
Homeland Security did not complete the
rulemaking process uh Menlo is not part
of any regulations at the government
level now
um as a researcher who later became an
employee at the Department of Homeland
Security told us
someone should have led the process with
rulemaking which we would we should have
tried to do that list but it would have
been a really heavy lift so it didn't
happen so sharing the report in the
Federal Register signaled that Menlo
authors intended to recruit powerful
existing regulation networks for
governance but menlo's recommendations
were never formally adopted by
government agencies
so instead menlo's primary influence on
the field was through academic networks
of peer review
conference committees became the ones to
effectively steer the ethics of security
and network measurement research by
cutting or refusing to publish research
that didn't inherit adhere to Menlo
recommendations
as an author accountant it's about
changing Norms you don't see it right
away and now I can point to top security
conferences that require ethical
statements I consider this a clear
victory
so though Menlo as we studied it was
governance in the making we do think it
helped move the field of network
measurement and computer security into a
mode of Ethics governance
after the report was published one of
the highest status conferences in the
computer security field usenix included
the following requirement and their call
for papers in 2013. papers that describe
experiments on human subjects or that
analyze non-public data derived from
Human subjects even anonymized data
should disclose whether an Ethics review
for example IRB approval was conducted
and discussed steps taken to ensure that
participants were treated ethically
other major network uh security computer
security and network measurement
conferences soon followed and we tracked
how many papers we're talking about
ethics and IRB in the years after the
publication of the memo report and the
introduction of the requirement to
discuss research ethics in some cases
the addition of such a requirement
doubled the number of accepted papers
discussing ethics and or review board
approval
and in 2019 the internet measurement
conference which is a major conference
in network measurement explicitly
included links to the Menlo report in
the call for papers
so we don't want to argue that Menlo
caused this effect of conferences
deciding we don't have the evidence that
that was the case but it coincided memo
coincided with governance changes in the
field that were associated with most
associated with the author groups and
the authors of Menlo went out to be on
these program committees in in some
cases so this was a change that was
happening in the field at the time
so I'm gonna head off to Megan now to
talk about the next process that we
discovered all right let me pause are
there questions you guys are so quiet
um which is great Katie and I both
obviously love to talk
um but please please interrupt us or
interrupt me if you have any questions
go inside with a shift in the topic
topic published in the conference like
where people doing more research that
might have human subjects yeah or or was
it already happening and now they were
just actually referencing so we've
collected this data at like a fairly
shallow level and are in the process of
analyzing it across this and we actually
collected data from a couple of other
conferences
um so I can't answer that yeah it's a
great great question and um which we
will one that we definitely will think
about any other yeah is there anything
has there been any personal statements
from people involved in these
conferences that they're aware of this
report and it changed maybe it was in
the discussions when they changed the
policy or anything like that yeah that's
a great um so we also haven't done those
interviews but that sounds like great
data to collect I'll say that
um our participants were also
um in program committees they were also
program chairs
um and we've collected some data about
how the MMO report authorship group
um became or didn't become
um sort of visible members of these
different conference communities the
data that's also much more interesting
is right like who's doing reviewing and
um to the extent that people are doing
reviewing and they're sending stuff back
and saying that it's not ethical that it
has been data I know that Katie's
actually formally tried to collect and
it's near impossible to get a hold of we
all hear about it anecdotally through
interviews that we do people will say
like oh yeah we and some of that shows
up in this data some of it shows up in
um another interview set that we have
but people will say yeah you know I read
this paper it made me really
uncomfortable I didn't know if it was
ethical I sent it back to the PC but
they don't necessarily even know as
reviewers right than what the PC does
with it um
great question
others okay oh yeah
do you know why the Mucinex conference
seemed to adopt
report or a kind of requirement of a
full disclosure earlier and then
secondly looking at the CCS conference
looked like it was all there was a jump
in and disclosures yeah for the adopters
yeah yeah yeah so that's a great
question so the second question if I had
to make a guess
um my understanding is that publication
practices in computer science are often
such that if your paper doesn't get into
one conference you might reuse it in
another conference with like a later I
know
maybe with an Ethics statement on it
right maybe that's some of the reason
right is somebody wrote a paper for a
usenix conference it didn't get in they
revised it but they kept it in some of
that ethics disclosure language in a
difference conference so that would be
that's a total hypothesis have not
looked into it yet again probably not
data that we can actually even get
although although I mean
Michael's question that I think is a
really good one is you know how much of
this is menloe reverberations and how
much is this topic change all of a
sudden are doing human subjects research
because the other thing that's changing
at this time and we talk about this from
our Menlo authors is that
um network data went from being
something that a few people had to
something that everybody's got right
like you could you can get your whole
universities Network and and track it
maybe you shouldn't or you know and so
all memo authors are struggling with
this and the field is struggling with
this so it's possible that some
especially these early pre-menlow
um sort of bumps are um are about you
know people having new controversial
methods and and responding to it with
ethics work right within Labs saying
okay and yeah we thought about this
right
and then the question around why use NYX
first
um so actually like internet measurement
conference and the first
um conference that we know of in this
sort of broader field of network
measurement and security to adopt this
requirement is actually a soups which I
don't know what that acronym stands for
but my understanding is that that's the
HCI meets security conference Symposium
privacy yes Symposium unusable privacy
and security nice job thank you Michael
the on is important here they adopt uh
requirements in 2009 and I think that
that's a lot because they're involved
with the HCI community and the security
community and so and I I've actually had
some conversations with people who were
sort of in the room when they adopted
that requirement and they said it was
basically this issue where people in HCI
were like of course if there's human
subjects you're talking about it in your
paper but that wasn't actually clear to
the security researchers so part of
putting that requirement in was actually
just articulating assumptions that one
research Community held close and you
know sort of assumed everybody
understood but another research
Community really didn't
um and so another guess about why use
NYX first is it might also be that
usenix had more of a presence of HCI
researchers and sort of like anecdotally
Katie and I might guess that but I have
no that's that's totally again us on our
part
really great questions you guys thank
you we have a good history to trace okay
I'm going to jump back into it then um
Okay so
moving back to our discussion about what
it means to do ethics governance in the
making
um our second sort of pillar here is we
found that ethics governance attempts to
repair the wrongs of the past in
anticipation for guiding the future
so one of the things that really
motivated researchers when we went and
asked them why did you volunteer your
efforts all of this precious time that
you have to write this report was that
they were really concerned that there
were papers in their field that had been
published and that these Publications
were communicating to other people in
this the field particularly their
students that there were research
methods that were acceptable that they
did not think were acceptable
um so we use this term repair to talk
about this effort to sort of go back
look at the past and fix it
um and we're borrowing this repair
language from from our field Science and
Technology studies I just want to know
we don't mean it in repair in the sense
of like giving restitution right
um it means that they're very much
looking the memo authors are looking at
specific Publications they're attempting
to identify their weaknesses and they're
producing guidance that they think
attends to these weaknesses
um
okay so repair is also really strongly
tied with this idea of anticipation as
you've guessed from probably what I've
said so far
um it means that the report in this
sense is both simultaneously looking to
the Past like what we did wrong and
looking to the Future what can we do
better
um and you know noting the gender
pronouns that our interview select
interviewee selected here
um this quote kind of perfectly
encapsulates that forward and backward
look the idea that it's trying to
anticipate the future and fix these
problems of the past others were looking
at ethically questionable work
um and he was publishing papers and they
were saying wow if he did it we can do
this right this was the this was the
problematic publication record that they
had to attend to to move forward into
the future
foreign
so our interviews were interested in
preparing repairing the past research
record but they also explained to us
that they weren't at this same level of
public urgency in which say like the
Belmont report was being written
um and there's this concept in public
policy and political science that they
talk about quote unquote focusing events
and these are events that are catalysts
for like major policy changes
um they're like the revelations around
the Tuskegee experiments that led to the
Belmont report are like a perfect
example of a quote-unquote focusing
event and importantly Menlo is really
not one of these situations
um our author said we're not infecting
people with syphilis we're not doing a
Milgram experiment that's going to
necessarily scar someone emotionally
there's a removal a distance between the
human beings and the researcher it was
not felt that it was quite as visceral
of a thing and so the Belmont report
really as you can tell loomed very large
as this paradigmatic example of Ethics
regulation but our participants felt
that there wasn't a lot of public
attention to Computing ethics at this
time right this is sort of in the mid
2000s
um they're very aware of these sort of
utopian imaginaries this sort of Savior
ideals discourses that are circulating
in the early 2000s when this project
originated right the so-called techlash
is really a decade away
okay but not having focusing events
didn't mean that there weren't problems
in the field there wasn't a Tuskegee
experiment but there were a lot of
controversial papers that were troubling
to many researchers and many funders and
part of the main report companion
document which was published about a
year after the Menlo report included a
list of papers in one of the appendices
that were presented as case studies but
could really be read as sort of like a
naming names
um that these were you know these were
sort of the notable papers that when we
asked uh our interviewees why did you
work on this project these were the
papers that they were pointing to they
they read one of these papers and they
thought uh oh like this isn't good for
our field
um
it wasn't the Tuskegee experiments right
but it was really really worrying to our
participants so I'm going to talk about
one of these papers which was published
in 2007 as a way of discussing one
example of what the memo authors were
reacting to
um when they started the project and
sort of illustrate this idea of what we
call like an atmosphere of concern and
measurement and security research at
that time and this example also helps
explain a bit about why this sort of
Ethics self-governance project took the
specific shape that it did right as
opposed to the sort of many other
different approaches to dealing with
these kinds of um to do dealing with
these kinds of problems so broadly many
of the concerning papers in this list
um in the memo companion document were
really fundamentally about information
flows like who gets to see what how and
in what circumstances and as Katie said
earlier information sharing was really
core to this project of predict program
program researchers are trying to
understand the characteristics of the
internet and its weaknesses and working
on the challenging the challenges that
they saw in preparing network data for
sharing but getting network data was not
easy it required networks of
Administrators that they would share
data and trusted researchers that they
were sharing the data with right
compromised data could affect the
security of the network and this paper
that I'm going to talk about is called
playing The Devil's Advocate it's
specifically addresses this problem
okay so what is this problematic paper
um The Devil's Advocate about it was
published in 2007
um
the paper is a play on the title of a
2006 paper called the devil uh and
packet trace anonymization and the
authors of this original paper the devil
and packet Trace anonymization paper
presented a method for anonymizing
network data network data that the
researchers had received from Lawrence
Berkeley National Labs and the
anonymized data set was shared with the
authors of playing The Devil's Advocate
who both de-anonymized the data and then
shared the details about the
de-anonymized data set and as the Menlo
authors explain the authors applied
um third genome anonymization techniques
to a publicly accessible data set
prominently used in the security
Community to prove the correctness of
their result they published key
information about the public data set in
their paper thus revealing the internals
about debt researchers Network de
anonymizing network data and revealing
networked in network information was
experienced as a severe violation of the
research Community Norms by the authors
of the original paper and others in the
community
and the authors of the devil
um and packet Trace anonymization almond
and Paxton
um had not expected that their
colleagues would de-anonymize the shared
data and share these details right so
they published a rebuke that is very
politely called titled issues and
etiquette concerning use of shared
measurement data and the authors
emphasize that no matter how careful a
network administrator was being that
they were always sharing more
information than they thought and they
reasoned that technology could not solve
many of the issues around data sharing
ethics and they said ultimately
the choice about what to release how to
obscure the data and whom to release the
data are policy decisions
emphasizing that better policies and
Norms needed to be established around
sharing research data they put forth
their suggestions for what kind of
policies would really be best for
mediating the sharing
data sharing Relationships by spelling
out acceptable uses of the data and
problematic papers such as playing The
Devil's Advocate
really in a sense contributed to this
atmosphere of concern that then opened
up this idea of policies of guidelines
of rules and even ethics as one of the
possible modes of addressing unethical
scholarship and at the very same session
in which almond and Paxton were talking
about this issues in Etiquette paper at
this major conference legal scholar Paul
ohm is presenting a paper that he
co-authored with two University of
Colorado computer scientists
um Doug stickler and Dirk Grunwald which
examined how U.S legislation applied to
network measurement researchers and it
explained legal issues went beyond data
sharing Norms to the legality of the
data collected and they're talking about
the federal wiretap act the pen register
track and Trace act and they suggested
that computer scientists were possibly
engaged in illegal activities
and the author is offered a number of
suggestions which move from repair to
anticipation to improve the likelihood
of following the law and they conclude
that at the very least we should proceed
informally by beginning to have a
conversation about what constitutes
acceptable network monitoring a codified
understanding that reflects even rough
consensus would be a useful tool to
bring to Congress or to show courts it
is important that these norms and rules
are agreed upon from within our
community rather than dictated To Us by
some outside court or agency
in order to repair the problematic
research records Scholars were arguing
for the needs of something like the
Menlo report to be created right and
importantly they argued that it should
be created by the research Community
itself and so for many of the authors
the memo report was exactly what om and
his colleagues were advocating for it's
this clear set of guidelines that was in
the Federal Register and could be hauled
before Congress
okay
stepping back to our framework
um so our third our third bucket is this
idea of anticipating future change which
I've also already briefly touched on
um memo authors anticipated future
research methods and attempted to create
guidelines to address these future
research methods they also anticipated
who might read the document possible
resistances to it and what the imagined
audience of the report might do and they
crafted the report for this imagined
audience
um as Katie said we're not going to talk
about this one in quite as much detail
so we can move on I'm going to pause
again and ask for questions any
questions
yes
people or not you know it was not quite
for that yeah
oh one of the examples you were using
most these kind of fundamental reports
were out of a crisis moment is there any
research around kind of I don't for
example I must be familiar with previous
research before the report on human
subjects yeah is there any Research into
like is it necessary to have that crisis
moment like if a report is made before
that crisis moment does that just reduce
the efficacy because people don't
understand the need for it yet I'm just
curious like if there's anything out
there about that
um so I let's see so I also work a lot
in the field of disaster studies and so
focusing moments are like a huge deal
because oftentimes there'll be like some
kind of Regulation or
um policy change that particularly like
scientific experts might have been
advocating for or Engineers have been
advocating for for years behind closed
doors and sometimes it takes one of
these like major disasters and then
suddenly people are like I guess we do
want anti-seismic building codes right
um and so you know you have these sort
of people who are standing in the wings
saying like and here it is right
um so in the in the sense of disasters
yes
I think Katie and I kind of are like
we're in this interesting I think
constitutional moment in Computing
ethics right now and I don't know if you
all saw there was
um a sort of call for uh AI ethics ideas
by the office ostp
um and the the heads the head to the
office for
um office of Science and Technology
policy
um so I think it sort of looks like
maybe we've we've been sort of in some
kind of prices but it's
um
yeah but I don't know and I think Katie
and I are hoping to tackle this actually
in our next research project
um about whether they're like these sort
of particular inflection moments where
these kinds of
um policy and or sort of Ethics
responses are particularly effective and
are taken up
um on Mass
it's a very good question it's literally
like sort of the work of our next couple
of years basically how big a crisis is a
crisis right and it's pretty clear in
disaster studies and it's a much less
clear and Computing right like what
constitute are some racist algorithms a
crisis maybe right but like uh but like
you know it's not an earthquake right so
then this like yes I think it's a really
good question but what was clear from
Menlo is that a few controversial papers
were not a crisis but they were worried
there might be one right um and so yes
is that the effective moment or do we
need to wait for the disaster yeah it's
a great empirical question yeah and I
think it's a little bit more complicated
because the racist algorithms have
existed for several decades without
being identified as a crisis and in the
last say like five to ten years a number
of excellent Scholars and activists have
said this is a crisis but the public
attention turning towards
um hey let's do something about that has
not been the kind of whiplash of an
earthquake
um nonetheless I think you know everyone
would argue yes this is a crisis or
hopefully in this class you'd argue that
this is a crisis
um but it doesn't have that sort of like
immediacy
um that maybe right like an earthquake
might have
um yeah
a piece that I didn't quite get from
yeah you're talking about the Devil's
Advocate paper was the was the ethical
concern with the topics that they were
exploring or was it with the methods
that they were publishing like they
should have redacted certain things in
the in their research
um my understanding was that it was the
the latter
um that it was the methods
um and that there were details shared
like through sharing these
de-anonymization techniques of the
network data set they share details
about that Network that were
inappropriate so I think it was like
sharing sharing the entire method if
that makes sense
[Music]
I think that also occurred around the
same time as I don't know if you all
remember uh I'm gonna guess no uh
Netflix at one point released this
really big data set of Netflix data and
I think it's kind of it's like a kind of
paradigmatic example in a lot of Ethics
classes of like nothing Netflix released
this data said help us improve our
algorithm and a bunch of like clever
computer scientists said we can sort of
figure out who's who in this data set
right
um
yeah it was and the other piece of it
was that the data sharing agreement the
data had been shared in de-identified
form the researchers felt that they
didn't understand that this group was
going to re-identify the data and so
that was it was a like a uh like a
disagreement amongst colleagues almost
that blew up into like is this ever okay
to do yeah
um
I'm gonna step quickly through this
number four
um so
as Katie noted one of the major
accomplishments of the Menlo report was
this explicit identification of computer
research as involving human subjects
research
and the authors of the Menlo report
believe that their colleagues for the
most part
um were trustworthy stewards of data but
they were concerned that sometimes their
colleagues didn't understand the fact
that they were working with data about
people
um so they really wanted to sort of
Shore that up and make that very clear
in the report
um and but by bringing in so they did
this by bringing in the uh the Belmont
principles which they were very
attracted to because they're simple
um they had this huge impact on on
policy and they've been very durable
right there aren't a lot of Ethics
principles that have been really useful
for decades and decades and decades I
shouldn't say that there aren't a lot of
Ethics principles that have been turned
into policies that have been useful for
decades upon decades
um but in bringing in the Belmont report
and the Paradigm of human subjects it
was like this really uncomfortable fit
um
as this quote from the memo report
illustrates they sort of say traditional
biomedical and behavioral research
requires this protection of natural
persons
um but within ICT research right
um it may be an information system
um uh Associated data and it complicates
the assessment of potential harm of
users to that system and that data it's
a lot more ambiguous it's not as clear
of a fit and so with the application of
the human subjects data associating
network data with human subjects it
enabled a really clear way forward for
the authorship group
um but it also codified a set of
governance mechanisms which is IRB
review which was not as easy of a way
forward for this group and so this
caused controversy this wasn't without
controversy within the group so on one
hand you had people who said you know
when we began at Menlo there was a
diversity opinions about the
applicability of Belmont to the network
security research and there was always
someone who would stand up and say well
we're not working with humans we're just
working with bites and I suppose one can
say well I'm not working on humans I'm
just working with blood samples I think
the argument is about as strong in both
cases and then on the other hand there
were there were participants who said
you know this we we don't want
everything to be reviewed by irbs this
is going to create this huge
bureaucratic structure for our
organization
and this led to some really new
uncertainties
um that the memo report introduced so
they said in some cases irbs didn't know
the law and researchers would go and do
things that were kind of in a gray area
or might have actually broken the law
and the IRB approved it because the irbs
did not necessarily have the expertise
in some kinds of network security
network and security Computing research
furthermore
and again this is kind of getting back
to some of the issues I was pointing out
earlier the potential harm of to
subjects in computer security research
is much more abstract as are the
benefits you don't really know how an
individual person might benefit to
consenting to research or what impacts
there might be in waiving consent for
monitoring Network traffic or just
relying on consent that's in the terms
of service that you click through
so it introduced all of these new
uncertainties to the research as well
okay fifth we found that ethics
governance attempted to close or settle
controversies so as I noted earlier
there were some really big controversies
around not only whether scholarship was
unethical but also whether it was
illegal and so to resolve those
controversies around legal practices the
memo report went a step further than
Belmont and they added this fourth
principle of respect for research um
sorry respect for the law and public
interest
but as we all know the law and public
interest are not always the same thing
right these sometimes compete with each
other
and so this this sort of edition of this
principle it really was this um
compromise amongst these different
groups of researchers some of whom felt
the law as it was was sufficient enough
um to ensure ethical research practice
and others who who definitely did not
feel that way
so despite appearing in the Federal
Register the Menlo report ultimately
governed by this partial Community
consensus rather than by law and
controversies of both ethics and law and
how they apply they still plagued this
broader research scientist community
okay so we have these five overlapping
processes that we argue are constitutive
of Ethics governance in the making
and as our discussion today hopefully
makes clear we also wanted to add the
sixth one which is that the memo report
now becomes the static document this
research this resource that's out in the
world that other people can draw on and
use but that in the process of sort of
laying all of this work down in the
document they also created new
uncertainties they created
um new controversies and they created
you know this new resource for everybody
to make use of
okay so as we've been talking about
computer science is definitely in this
area of really interesting
experimentation with ethics governance
in the making across a number of
different fields now
um researchers and activists are
undertaking really interesting projects
to revise ethics codes rate new ethics
guidance form new committees within
computer science conferences and
professional associations
and to dictate ethics requirements for
funding and propose new ethics
requirements for publication and so
we're starting a new project we would
love ideas if you guys have
um sort of examples of field sites that
we should look at we're looking both
contemporarily and historically and our
ongoing project we hope is going to
document the efficacy of historical
current and emergence ethics governance
in computer science
um you guys thank you for your time and
thank you for all of the great questions
we have time for I'm really sorry we
meant to have time for 15 minutes of
questions but you have so many good ones
in the middle we have time for three
questions three minutes of questions so
maybe can I just get all the hands and
then we'll try to take them all and
answer them quickly yeah
good point talking about law it seems
like there's
Centric like participants in having
Homeland Security involved but also
trying to set standards for a discipline
of transcends the United States I was
wondering if the participants talked
about that from the continues at all
great question any other questions you
guys want us to take
um so again we have we have interviews
from sort of like a broader set of folks
and that is definitely a concern outside
of the US
um is like hey we don't have irbs in our
country and you're asking us to you know
um report as though in our papers to
write as though we have the option of
Consulting an IRB about human subjects
and we don't
um and so one of the things actually in
the National academies report that we
suggested was that
um professional associations maybe
develop some of these
um institutional resources for folks who
maybe don't have access to that at their
home institution and you know we don't
specifically talk about IRB resources
per se but something like stamp like
what your professor's been working on
this amazing ethics review board here at
Stanford is something that Stanford has
the resources to do but many
universities in the United States may
not and so maybe professional
associations are one place in which you
can develop that kind of resource that
could be used throughout the community
it's a great question yeah
um so I study first of all thank you so
much for your presentation I study
programming practices and their value
implications on how work happens and
what technologies ultimately get built
um I'm curious to know if the
technologists and Community scientists
who you talk to reflected on the
connection between the values
um that usually programmers have to
wrestle with at the dying software is
written and the values of the
technologies that get built ultimately
do you want to take that yeah yeah so
this is a question that I'm super super
interested in and one that I've spent a
lot of time thinking about and I would
say it for in at Menlo the men the Menlo
group no does that seem reasonable to
you yeah no that would not be how they
frame it partially because of this sort
of repair work that they were doing
um it was really you know they were
focused on uh their methods as a field
so this actually and one thing I think
we should we should say about Menlo is
Menlo is not about how to develop new
technologies particularly it is a set of
research practice
um uh recommendations and so they were
talking about methods and methods in
their field which of course have
technical innovation in them
um but that was really the focus uh and
so the focus was not on the values of
computer security the ways those values
have been instantiated in new designs
that is a dialogue that was starting to
happen at the same time within HCI
um and but doesn't merge with computer
security at this particular men moment
um and so it's a great question
um it was it's not how I would
characterize the Menlo dialogue you see
much more of that now right it's a very
common way of talking about Technologies
now that has changed since Menlo Katie
and Dan Green have a really great paper
that looks at this question around app
developers thinking about privacy but I
don't remember what the paper is called
do you oh gosh yes not off the top of my
head okay but if you yeah it's uh yeah
email her yes but that sort of values
debate does happen in technical
communities but it's much more on the on
the build side right like when people
are building Technologies
um this was about governing research
practices and data sharing practices
it's a different set of focus
thank you so much
excellent I think we're about in time so
let's thank our speakers thank you guys